when we say a face is symmetric what we
mean is that you can reflect it about a
line and it's left looking completely
the same it's a statement about an
action that you can take something like
a snowflake is also symmetric but in
more ways you can rotate at 60° or 120°
you can flip it along various different
axes and all these actions leave it
looking the same a collection of all of
the actions like this taken together is
called a group take note we always
consider the action of doing nothing to
be part of the group so if we include
that do nothing action the group of
symmetries of a snowflake includes 12
distinct actions it even has a fancy
name
D6 the simple group of symmetries that
only has two elements acting on a face
also has a fancy name
C2 in general there is a whole zoo of
groups with no shortage of jargon to
their names categorizing the many
different ways that something can be
symmetric